every few years you might hear about el
nino in the news and this also might
come with
powerful images of flooding and rainfall
but el nino is not just a storm it's
actually a climate pattern
that takes place in the pacific ocean
and we'll get a little bit more into
what that actually means
now a fun fact about how el nino was
named
is that a long time ago south american
fishermen noticed
one december that the pacific ocean was
actually
warmer than it normally is and this
brought about an abundance of fish
so because they were grateful they named
this event el nino to
correlate with the commemoration of
christ in this part of the world
during christmas time so that's a little
trivia you can keep in your
back pocket but back to um what we hear
about el nino in the news
you might also notice that it doesn't
isn't talked about
every single year and that's because el
nino comes around
every two to seven years on average
and scientists are still not sure
exactly what triggers el nino but they
know what signs to look for
once it is approaching or once we're in
that
event so even though it's true that el
nino can bring about heavy rainfall
and flooding it can also cause severe
drought
so it's really important to note that
different
regions around the world
experience different effects of el nino
and we'll see a few examples of those so
sometimes an el nino year is actually
a little bit helpful and might bring
about some much needed rain
but other times bigger and more severe
el nino events can bring
devastating weather events all across
the globe so we can look at the
different effects by looking at the
biggest el nino
on record during the 1997-1998 season
and we can see how different regions
were affected so for example in
california
we saw very destructive mudslides
in ecuador there was heavy rainfall
and in indonesia there was actually
extreme
drought and fire
and overall this el nino event was
really large and very destructive there
are estimates of about
36 billion dollars in damage
to infrastructure so you might be asking
yourself
how can the same climate pattern cause
such drastically different effects
around the globe so to understand this
better we have to look at what a
quote-unquote
normal year looks like so this is a map
of the pacific ocean
and normally there are trade winds that
are pushing
warm water towards the west so towards
asia and the pacific islands and
warm water accumulates on this side
on the other side on the east side near
central and south america we have an
accumulation of cool water
and this is also due to a process called
upwelling
where cold water from the bottom of the
ocean is pushed
up and during these conditions in
general
you would see less rain on this side
while you'll see more rain
on this side okay so now let's look at
what changes during an
el nino year so during an el nino year
you still have trade winds pushing water
west
but they're much weaker and that's the
key here
that your trade winds are weakened which
means less
water is pushed towards asia
and the pacific islands so compared to a
normal year you actually have cooler
water that starts to accumulate
on this side of the pacific ocean
meanwhile
on the other side since less water is
being pushed away
from central and south america you get
more
warm water accumulating so now you can
think back to those south american
fishermen
and why they were experiencing warm
water
along their coasts during an el nino
year
so this map does a really great job of
showing the temperature gradient and how
this
warm water is staying along the coast of
central and south america
during an el nino year meanwhile you
have
cold water accumulating towards
asia and this causes a lot of
changes that affect weather patterns so
in the u.s
the pacific jet stream moves south of
its neutral position
and because of that we start to see that
the northern u.s
and canada are actually warmer and drier
than they usually are
the u.s gulf coast and southwest regions
of the u.s
are wetter and at a more increased risk
for flooding
and south asia and the pacific islands
experience warmer and drier conditions
that lead to drought
on the other side of the pacific ocean
so now you start to see how one event el
nino this one climate pattern can cause
both um flooding on one side
of the pacific ocean while also causing
drought
on the other side and finally we'll end
with la nina
because you might hear this come up too
when talking about el nino
so la nina is essentially the opposite
so if you've got el nino down you can
start to understand what happens
during a la nina event so in this
situation
our trade winds are getting stronger
than our normal years so they're pushing
water west
but they're doing so even more than we
normally would expect
so this warm water that accumulates
towards asia actually accumulates more
west than it than it would during our
normal years
and on the other side we have even more
upwelling
causing this cold water to accumulate
so the next time you hear el nino or la
nina in the news you'll know that
they're not just talking about
a really big storm but they're actually
talking about
climate patterns that can affect weather
all across the globe